as we have seen this past weekend in las
vegas travelers coming back strong
and it was during today's fourth quarter
earnings call from when executives
reported how omicron did affect
occupancy especially group events here
in las vegas now they expect occupancy
at 80 percent next month revenue from
the last quarter of 2021 was 1.05
billion dollars that's an increase of
more than 53 percent from 2020 wynn
resorts also announcing a sale lease
back arrangement for encore boston
harbor the sales proceeds will go
towards development projects and other
debt ceo craig billings discussed plans
for a resort in the united arab emirates
we will be licensed to conduct gaming in
rav ohio in other words we're go with
this project i expect our ultimate
design will be one or more iconic
buildings that both take advantage of
the pristine beach location and also
show respect for the unique cultural
aspects of the region
additional news here in las vegas the
encore is reconstructing the larev
theater putting a new show in place and
win in las vegas rooms are being
renovated